just a trickle of vultures around
Tunisia polling stations remain by and
large empty for electoral workers a long
sluggish election day the few casting
their ballots mostly from the older
generation
retirees like Hassan Sharif who believes
is their duty to vote
the country is going to hell and people
are not voting till one will remain in
the same situation
Parliament without political parties
will be better because parties in the
Arab world don't work for the sake of
their country
the election comes after tunisia's
president Kai Saeed first suspended
parliament in July 2021 and they solved
it a few months later
tunisians have shown very little
interest in this election during the
first round back in December only 11
percent of registered voters cast their
ballot and when you ask people why they
tell you they don't believe the new
Parliament will have the power to work
in their favor
around the capital there is little sign
that an election is taking place the
opposition has boycotted the vote but
it's people's apathy that should concern
the president more he got a very a huge
blow to his political road map there is
no question about that and they cannot
say with confidence that he's talking on
behalf of the people because this is the
sentence he keeps repeating that he is
basically implementing the will of the
people which is basically the basic
populist slogan and that's what Kaiser
say it is the low turnout will also
reflect on the legitimacy of the new
Parliament
when he's saying that it won't represent
them
so it's the future of the country
elected by nine or eight percent uh
percentage so it's not good for the
future of the country for for our our
pictures with with the world
it's not good
after 10 years of the Revolution and the
the the trust of the people of the in
the in the politic man
really it's it's bad
for for our country for our future with
inflation at nearly 10 percent tunisians
are more concerned about their
livelihoods and survival but the economy
has not been a priority for the
president who's focused on political
reform the turnout of this election a
reflection of how much he has alienated
tunisians who put their hope in him Al
Jazeera Tunis